[Music]
Time magazine is out this morning with
it's time 100 list of the world's most
influential people global leaders like
President Trump and China Xi Jingping
are in the company of athletes
entertainers and an architect
philanthropist Melinda Gates grace is
one of the five covers of this issue she
is joined by Jeff Bezos Viola Davis and
wrist and an R is ahmud also John Legend
the internship Nancy gift joins us now
good morning good morning one more time
for anybody who has not followed this
every year or in a cage or in a cave yes
or both yeah
how do you select them what are you
looking for it's a year-long
conversation where we're keeping track
not just of people who were powerful in
traditional senses but people who are
who are fascinating who are moving the
needle in whatever different field
well good or bad for good or bad it's
you know the power is a tool influences
a skill it's a different kind of effect
that they have on what we talk about
what we focus on what we're interested
in and so there are people on the list
who are very traditionally famous of
heads of state and CEOs but then there
are people a lot of people will have
never heard of who are who are acting in
their realms in ways that are sure to be
enormous ly potent for years to come
you always say Nancy that there are no
automatics although you think if you're
President of the United States or China
or the Pope you've got a pretty good
shot at being on the list you do it's
not every year but they have I would say
that they've got managed like the Trump
administration is well represented this
year you've got five people from the
Trump administration on the list well
anytime you've got a new administration
you know we're watching these people
very closely but in this case you know
they came in with so little most cases
with so little experience in government
and such a promise through the campaign
that they were going to blow it up
anyway that we knew that things were not
going to be the same in the West Wing as
they have been before and indeed that is
one of the one of the promises that has
been kept in the course of the first
hundred days and so we're watching them
even as you know that West Wing is
likened to a kind of Game of Thrones
atmosphere but each of each of them is
influential in a way not just their own
role but in how we think about public
service and the role of advisors to the
president I think what's so brilliant
about it to not only the list and who
you choose in its pan
and athletes science actors politicians
the gamut is who you choose to write
about them the pairings Jared Kushner
who has taken on an outsized role at the
White House Henry Kissinger writes about
him
and says we have subrata cailli
exchanged views really interesting sort
of his brief take on Kushner's influence
so your Kissinger has watched a lot of
administration's come and go and he
understands the the thermodynamics of
the White House as well as anyone and
I'm interested that he and to promote
dynamics with a little bit of a warning
about you know Kushner as he as he flies
close to the Sun now we've already seen
some of the people around President
Trump already have their wings you know
burned and melt so I think that that was
both you know a a tribute to the fact
that the Kushner is navigating very very
difficult territory elton john on james
corden Elton John Jane repai James
Corden who you know Gordon was very well
known in the UK for his role in in
various sitcoms and Gavin and Stacey
here he you know until he took over the
The Late Late Show I'm not sure that
people really knew him but in a year
like this especially someone who doesn't
just make a smile but you know makes us
importance at a great yes yes agent Lee
remain nameless I'm very excited about
that listen she's had a great year but
next year when she does wrinkle in time
for Disney you can abstruse but it's so
great she made the list you chose her
why well you know like Barry Jenkins
also yes on the left of moonlight we're
seeing these incredibly versatile
directors who are also writers producers
Jordan Peele with get-out same thing
where they are leaving their mark in
their medium in by being multi-talented
in ways that are just extraordinary but
not only Tom Brady also Colin happening
so there we have two athletes two
quarterbacks one of whom is there very
much for what he did on the field and
Tom Brady is extraordinary you know
Super Bowl triumph and one for what he
did next to the field in the way Colin
Kaepernick invited a different
conversation about the nature of
patriotism and protest in this country
Pope Francis is the only religious
leader right to make the list and
there's a question now about whether
Trump will see him in Italy coming up in
the coming weeks that will be very
interesting to see I think you know
Charlie you remember when this when we
met him in the fall and I think
everyone is struck by this incredible
global figure who the first words out of
his mouth you know or pray for me the
the way he has captured the imagination
of people far beyond people who would
normally follow the pronouncements
coming out of the Vatican I think as a
global moral leader on the environment
on the refugee crisis on income
inequality really he continues to make
his voice heard far beyond the pulpit
that he would normally we have to go
Nancy but could I just point out that
Charlie Rose made the list you feel the
greatness don't you he is indeed one of
our great time 100 alumni we feel that
too yeah
love it it's such a good such good issue
with different covers which is great to
everybody we'll see if John loaded you I
love this Nancy Gibbs always great to
have you here thank you so much